Hey, Vsauce. Michael here. If we turned
the Moon into a giant disco ball,
day and night would not
be a disco party. Instead of diffusely
reflecting sunlight onto
all of us, a mirror-tiled moon would reflect
specularly. You would be lucky to momentarily
catch a single reflected beam of sunlight.
Now, with the help visuals by Nick from
Yeti Dynamics, who you should subscribe to
immediately, let's see what would occur
if a disco ball moon actually happened.
Here's the Earth with an imaginary
screen behind it, so we can track the
path of reflections
from a disco ball Moon. It's 3,012 mirror
tiles are ten kilometres thick
and between 100 and 150 kilometres
across. And, as you can see, the beams of sunlight they
reflect would only intersect with Earth briefly
and rarely - a few every month or so would
race past at more than 20,000 kilometers a second.
From the surface of Earth, they'd just be
tiny flashes in the sky
0.1 percent as bright as the regular Sun
and would last a fraction of a second.
The Earth, Sun and Moon just
aren't an ideal locations for disco ball effects.
But, if our disco ball moon was closer
and orbited earth not 384,000 kilometers away but
less than 450, as far as the
International Space Station does,
it would be torn apart by gravitational
title forces. Shoot. Also, the Moon doesn't really
rotate from our perspective like a fun disco ball.
It liberates, but it's starting to look
like instead of an awesome lunar party decoration,
a disco ball moon would just be a lunar party pooper.
So, for the sake of investigation, let's
allow this disco ball Moon to not be torn apart
and allow it to spin in the sky. Now we're talking.
Occasionally we would get glittery
reflections of a dimmer image
of the Sun. From the surface of Earth,
this is what we would see.
You know, being able to see
Earth reflected is almost cooler. It's like being
a bacterium on a giant's face who's looking into a mirror.
You can see the giant, but not yourself.
It kinda makes you feel small.
But it would be a great way to take planetary selfies.
So, let's watch a mirror the width of the
Moon orbit as close as the ISS does.
From the surface of Earth, it would look like this.
The strobe lights around the edge, by
the way, are ten kilometres across.
Pretty cool.
Now finally, let's take a look at the
Moon as a rotating disco ball from low orbit.
The Moon is not a disco ball
and likely never will be. It's just
a diffuse source of illumination. But it's
illuminating in a different way to imagine
what would occur
if that actually happened.
Woah.
And as always,
thanks for watching.